like I'm going to try to speedrun and
power through this review you got better
things to do than listen to me talk
about this movie I got better things to
do than to talk about this movie so
let's just get it
[Music]
done you're still here well bless you
you make it all worth it in my book
everyone else bailed play their balers
Gate 3 but not you you stuck around and
that makes you mighty so founders day is
a
movie it's a throwback to 90s Slasher in
this small horror movie town There's an
election going on in this little town
all the while there's a killer out there
in a purge mask and a wig bludgeoning
people to death with a gavl this movie
has the biggest case of identity crisis
I noticed that early on when I was like
who's the main character in this thing
who's the Sydney Prescott the Nancy
Thompson the Lorie Strode is clear
enough at a point is Naomi Grace's
character but this movie spends so much
time concentrating on other characters
Side characters possible victims
possible Killers also the movie is
absolutely blute cheese characters in
this movie just act like cartoons some
characters more consistently than others
there other characters in the movie
though they act perfectly normal then at
a point it's like why are you acting
cartoony and I know there's a probable
counterargument I might run into in the
comments section if I am exercising the
art of YouTube which is the art of the
straw man this movie is supposed to be a
slasher film parody they're supposed to
act cartoony it's done that way
purposefully I get it I get it in the
same way I get that shitty tasting
coffee is still coffee but if it tastes
like [__] it's only fair to call it as
it is same thing kind of and it comes
down to entertainment and fun factor I
just wasn't laughing it wasn't ever
funny but it's clearly trying to be
funny in parts so I felt like I was just
sitting there watching Bad standup
comedy you know how a we've all been
there you know how awkward that can get
there were times it was clearly trying
to be more serious and then other times
it was trying to be a parody it almost
feels like and this is just I'm just
telling you how it feels not telling you
how it happened but it feels like while
this movie was being filmed someone was
cutting it together in the editing room
and someone made the call like look this
is not Landing I'm sure we can Rebrand
and lean into it being some sort of
parody cheesy comedy thing here's hoping
but since movies are filmed out of order
you have this serious and campy tone
that intermittently just flows and Es
throughout it inconsistently again I
don't know I wasn't there it's probably
not how it went down I'm just saying how
it feels but if at a point I found out
that's how it did go down I would not be
the least bit surprised this movie is so
screamed too you have the Dewey
character even has the mustache I will
say the end of the movie you know the
reveal a movie like this is always going
to have a reveal there was definitely
something clever there I be honest I was
like I I can see something here bummer
is the rest of the movie getting here
was a [__] slog it's boring it's
cheesy but still not fun or funny did
not have engaging characters I'm not
going to remember any characters from
this movie at all actually scratch that
there is one there is one because I saw
this dude I was like I recognized that
guy took me about four and a half
seconds I was like who was Corey
Matthew's dad from Boy Meets World okay
so I'll remember him but I'll remember
him because Cory Matthew's dad from Boy
Meets World in a world where it's Dollar
Store Thanksgiving more to the point it
feels like Dollar Store Eli Roth I don't
think that's a title any movie actually
wants but there we are maybe in 20 years
people will point back to reviews like
this and be like see people didn't even
like this movie when it came out now
it's a classic until then I just wanted
out of this thing I almost left early
glad I didn't because the wrapup was
actually the best part of the movie but
all in all the movie
remains dog [__] one thing that bothered
me in the movie and I legitimate I don't
think it was the auditorium I was in was
there were scenes when music would just
blast blare in the film it was so loud
it was so much louder than the voices in
the center channel I kind of want to
give the movie the benefit of the doubt
maybe someone at the movie theater had
the auditorium eqed incorrectly I don't
know I bring it up because if someone
else watched this movie did you run into
that like that twom minute long segment
where it's just music blasting where you
like yeah okay well I'll just wait this
one out all right so founders day have
you seen it what did you think about it
what's your favorite cult classic or bad
slasher movie we all have him and we all
love him [__] yours might be founders
day whatever it is comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see
[Music]
more